>>> FROM THE CREATORS OF NA
AND AFRAID.
IT'S NAKED AND AFRAID CELEB
EDITION.
THE SHOW WHERE TWO CELEBRIT
USE THEIR SKILLS TO SURVIVE
NAKED IN THE WILD FOR 21 DA.
>> I THINK I AGREED TO DO T
SHOW BECAUSE I LIKE TO TEST
LIMITS, CHALLENGE MYSELF.
>> I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS, WH
ARE WE SUPPOSED TO GET NAKE?
[ CAR HORN ]
>> OH, THERE'S A CAR, IT MUE
MY PARTNER.
>> WHOO!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THE COOL BREEZE FEELS GON
MY ASS, MAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHEN MY AGENT ASKED ME I
WANTED TO APPEAR ON THE SHO
NAKED.
I WAS LIKE YEAH.
BUT THEN HE WAS LIKE, HEY,
FULL TITLE IS "NAKED AND
AFRAID."
I'M LIKE, WHAT AM I AFRAID
I'M LESLIE JONES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHOO!
PETER DINKLAGE ARE YOU KIDD
ME RIGHT NOW?
I'M SUCH A BIG FAN, MAN.
THIS IS GOING TO BE SO DOPE.
HEY, LET ME JUST START OFF
SAYING, YOU ARE PACKIN'.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> BEFORE THE CHALLENGE, A
OF EXPERTS GAVE PETER AN INL
PRIMITIVE SURVIVAL RATING O
4.1 FOR BEING AN AVID HIKER
COMPLETING COMBAT TRAINING
"GAME OF THRONES."
AND LESLIE WAS GIVEN AN INI
PSR OF 5.7 FOR SURVIVING
COMPTON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> FOR THE 21 DAY CHALLENGE
PETER AND LESLIE WERE EACH
ALLOWED TO BRING ONE SURVIV
ITEM.
>> MAN, TELL ME YOU BROUGHT
SOMETHING GOOD.
>> YEAH, I BROUGHT A FIRE
STARTER KIT, YOU KNOW.
>> NICE, BUT I GOT YOU BEAT.
FRANK'S RED-HOT.
>> WHY DID YOU BRING HOT SA?
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO BRING
SOMETHING TO SURVIVE WITH?
>> HEY, THIS IS A SURVIVAL ,
OKAY?
I PUT THIS [ BLEEP ] ON
EVERYTHING.
DON'T START WITH ME ON DAY
TYRION.
>> SHE KNOWS MY NAME ISN'T
I TOLD HER SEVERAL TIMES TOL
ME PETER.
>> PETER IS A WHINY BITCH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OKAY?
DID YOU KNOW HE'S A VEGETAR?
ALL WE'VE BEEN EATING IS LE.
AND NOT ONCE, NOT ONCE DID
COMPLIMENT MY BODY.
IT'S LIKE, YOU DON'T WANT T?
DUMB [ BLEEP ].
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WITH NIGHTTIME APPROACHI
PETER AND LESLIE MUST BUILD
SHELTER TO PROTECT THEMSELV
FROM THE ELEMENTS.
>> THE [ BLEEP ] TAKING YOU
LONG?
>> I'M BUILDING US A PLACE
SLEEP, LESLIE.
>> OH, WELL, MAKE SURE YOU D
US A BIG OLD BED TOO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SHE'S A REAL HORN DOG.
SERIOUS.
HOW IS THERE NOT AN OPEN SE
HARASSMENT CASE AGAINST HER?
>> LESLIE, I CAN'T BREATH.
YOU'RE CRUSHING ME.
>> I'M NOT CRUSHING YOU.
I'M SAVING YOUR LIFE.
THIS IS BODY WARMTH.
>> WHY IS YOUR HAND DOWN TH?
>> THAT'S WHERE THE WARMESTT
IS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GO TO SLEEP, TYRION.
>> AFTER 12 DAYS OF EATING
LEAVES, TENSIONS RISE.
>> THE WOMAN'S COMPLETELY
INSANE.
>> TYRION, SAVE ME!
>> ALL SHE DOES IS TALK ABO
KEEPING IT REAL.
>> I KEEP IT REAL, YO.
>> YOU KEEP IT LOUD.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, BECAUSE IT
REAL.
>> AFTER SURVIVING 21 DAYS
THE WILD.
PETER AND LESLIE FINALLY MAT
TO THE EXTRACTION POINT.
LESLIE'S PSR LOWERED BY TWOL
POINTS FOR BREAKING THE SHOO
DRUG POLICY.
AND HER SEVERAL ATTEMPTS TO
HER PARTNER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> COME BACK YOU TASTY MORS!
>> HOWEVER, PETERS PSR LEVE
ROSE THREE POINTS AFTER SUR
21 DAYS WITH LESLIE.
A FEAT NO MAN HAS EVER ACHI.
>> GIVE ME THEM STICKS.
>> WELL, WE SURVIVED.
>> WE MADE IT TOGETHER, YOU
KNOW?
>> I THINK I'M ACTUALLY GOIO
MISS YOU.
>> COME HERE, MAN, GIVE ME
HUG.
>> I LOVE YOU, TYREE.
>> PETER.
>> WHATEVER MAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]